ja es geht auch um das thema cdu in dem
fall geht um die bundeskanzlerin um die
scheidende bundeskanzlerin die ja quasi
in basta mentalität noch mal ein thema
abgeräumt hat dass das land hier über
jahre und noch immer noch bewegt das
thema ist die flüchtlingskrise von 2015
damals hat angela merkel einen
bemerkenswerten satz gesagt sie hat
gesagt wir schaffen das hat das ein
bundesbürgern zugerufen hat dafür
massive kritik einstecken müssen jetzt
hat angela merkel in einem interview
gesagt als zurück blinde quasi als
rückblick auf das nach sechs jahren ja
wir haben das geschafft angela merkel
schließt einfach dieses kapitel
flüchtlingskrise für sich in basta
mentalität und sagt es hat alles
wunderbar geklappt wenn man auf die
zahlen schaut dann muss man doch
feststellen so einfach frau
bundeskanzlerin geht das nicht denn wir
wissen beispielsweise dass gerade bei
den frauen also bei denen die zu uns
gekommen sind vor firmen jahren nicht
mal ein drittel dieser frauen dieser
weiblichen flüchtlinge einen job haben
also sprich einen ausbildungsplatz ein
minijob oder ein ganz regulären job bei
den männern sind es nicht mal zwei
drittel wir wissen aber beispielsweise
das auch zwei drittel der syrer derzeit
von hartz 4 leben zwei drittel der syrer
die in deutschland sind und beim thema
kriminalität lohnt auch ein blick in die
statistik ist nämlich deutlich gestiegen
was die ausländischen tatverdächtigen
angeht deutlich gestiegen seit 2005 10
antworten es ist viel zu früh hier schon
ein schlussstrich zu ziehen eine bilanz
zu ziehen und sicherlich ist es völlig
falsch zu sagen ja wir haben das
geschafft denn wir sind noch mittendrin
und komplett können wir überhaupt noch
nicht sagen ob wir das geschafft haben
das zweigeteilter meinung zum einen bin
ich ja vor allem wegen der
flüchtlingskrise ein fan von angela
merkel nicht so wie das landes umgesetzt
hat aber es war ein historischer
humanitären akt und ich war froh in der
zeit deutsch zu sein ich war stolz
darauf dass frau merkel ist gemacht hat
und ich fragen wie mal was wenn die
andere lösung gewesen dass wir also eine
grenze dann da entschieden hätten das
kind kommt noch rein die frau kommen
noch ein also da wäre jetzt meine frage
an dich was war für dich eine
praktikable lösung gewesen und das
zweite ist ich finde es immer so
schwierig dass über dieses
flüchtlingsproblem sprechen ich finde
wir haben ein integrationsproblem und da
müssen wir natürlich ganz schnell boris
palmer bei letzten zu gast beim film
nach acht er hat gefordert lasst die
flüchtlinge nicht arbeitslos sein weil
die wahrheit ist nämlich nicht dass alle
flüchtlinge super voll zu hause ist und
nicht arbeiten wollen die wahrheit ist
ich hab' 2018 auch im flüchtlingsheim
gearbeitet die wahrheit ist dass viele
zurückgehalten werden weil sie kriegen
keine arbeitserlaubnis und in diesen
heimen werden sie zusammen gefertigt so
kann integration nicht glücken deswegen
wäre meine aufforderung lieber lasst uns
endlich mit der guten integration
beginnen aber ich finde immer frau
merkel wir schaffen das nicht ich finde
das führt immer eher dazu dass die
gesellschaft noch mehr gegen die
flüchtlinge ist integration er niemals
mehr als als these um mal darüber
nachzudenken was eigentlich dahinter
steckt ist das schon richtig man braucht
eine these um sich mit dem thema zu
beschäftigen und für eine
bestandsaufnahme aus merkels sicht oder
aus unserer sicht ist dieser satz
einfach zu wenig da stimme ich ihm zu
ich war auch für die flüchtlingspolitik
von merck bin es immer noch als es für
richtig als sie vor der grenze standen
erst ab es kam was sollte man damals bin
ich nach wie vor der meinung aber wir
können erstens hat sie es über die jahre
abgelehnt ein integrationsministerium
einzurichten wenn man es dass man mit
helmut kohl vergleich der bei den bei
den ersten aufkommenden atomunfall in
tschernobyl tc 1 1 umweltministerium
eingerichtet hat auf bundesebene und für
reaktor schutz der hat sofort reagiert
merkel hat auf das problem gar nicht
reagiert hat es den verschiedenen
instanzen überlassen und das fand ich
immer zu wenig statt eine aktive
integrationspolitik zu betreiben
zweitens gehört zur bilanz dazu das was
wir heute aus weißrussland erleben als
organisierte sehen wir ja gerade heute
flüchtlingszug zur polnischen grenze
begleitet vom weißrussischen really teer
und gesagt wird dass nach gestellt was
wir damals
über den balkan erlebt haben und das
kann man inzwischen wissen das ist
nämlich ein teil der wahrheit auch herr
erdogan in der türkei hat busse zur
küste fahren lassen voller flüchtlinge
um sie dort aber auch er war ein
schlepper um druck auf die europäische
union auszuüben weil sie ihn nicht
aufgenommen vollständig schwierigkeiten
waren er hat die flüchtlinge auf boote
setzen lassen und in die türkei nach
griechenland übersetzen lassen das ist
die blaupause für das gewesen was
lukaschenka heute in weißrussland macht
muss man einfach selbstkritisch zur
kenntnis wir haben gerade gefangen die
sandten in budapest was hätte man machen
sollen ja also wenn man es überspitzt
formuliert man kann es auch so machen
wie die polnische regierung lehne die
belarus regierung sondern in polen unser
nachbarland noch mit dem polen
verheiratet so geht es natürlich auch ob
das ist in unserer moralischen sinne
oder in unserem namen wir tun jetzt ja
gerade so als wenn es nicht wenn es nur
um diesen budapester bahnhof gingen
gehen würde das ist ja ein eigentlicher
der fall sondern der budapester bahnhof
genau das war der anfang und dann sahen
wir über wochen ja über monate
flüchtlings züge nach deutschland kommen
eine bundeskanzlerin die sich sogar noch
dagegen gewehrt hat grenzen zu schließen
und den österreichischen bundeskanzler
dafür kritisiert hat dass das gemacht
hat die hat mich meine die balkanroute
geschlossen von der sie mit ihrer
politik aber dann profitiert hat weil
dann der flüchtlingsstrom nämlich
abgeschnitten oder beendet wurde also
sie profitierte davon im land hat aber
den bundeskanzler gescheut und deswegen
noch einmal ganz konkret die frage was
hätte ich gemacht im land die der punkt
ist ja ein anderer also wir haben
darüber gesprochen beispielsweise auch
dass die aufgaben so groß sind wie
zuletzt bei der deutschen bewältigung
der deutschen einheit da sind wir jetzt
im jahr 30 oder 31 und sprechen immer
noch darüber was es noch ein problem
gibt wie kann ich jetzt nach sechs
jahren bereits ein schlussstrich ziehen
und sagen ja hat alles wunderbar
geklappt wir haben das geschafft das ist
einfach eine anmaßung das kann diese
bundeskanzlerin nicht tun also
integrationsarbeit ist sicherlich ein
langfristiges projekt aber das jetzt mit
der deutschen einheit zu vergleichen ist
doch ein stückchen weit hergeholt
letztendlich gehören zur integration
immer beide seiten ja sowohl wir als
gast geben das land aber natürlich auch
die menschen die zu uns kommen ich kann
aus politischer sicht schon sagen dass
wir unglaublich viel unternommen haben
um zunächst einmal die gesetzlichen
grundlagen für eine gute und aktive
integrationsarbeit zu leisten
was ich aber feststellen ist dass der
politische wille in diesem land
integration
nicht nur zu ermöglichen sondern auch
einzufordern und im zweifel auch mit
konsequenzen zu belegen nicht vorhanden
ist ja ja also wir haben alle länder die
nicht in dem maße die rückführungen
durchführen wie sie es könnten und wie
sie es müssten also wir haben wirklich
auch schlupflöcher an vielen stellen wir
haben auch ein rechtssystem das
natürlich vielen migranten die
möglichkeit gibt dauerhaft auch den ihr
bleiberecht zu erwirken und das sind
alles ein stück weit auch rechts lücken
und fehler auch im system die wir auch
beheben müssen und man darf noch eines
hinzufügen die entscheidungen von 2015
kann man so oder so sehen aber am ende
hat das auch zu einer spaltung unserer
gesellschaft geführt wir diskutieren
heute noch an den mittagstischen bei der
oma bei dem oberthema wäre die
alternative gewesen es wird darüber
debattiert aber alternative ist
die alternative ist doch ganz klar ich
habe budapest gehabt und habe auch
gesehen was das für eine sogwirkung
ausgestrahlt hat und es haben uns auch
andere länder vorgemacht österreich hat
doch dann am ende ein ganz klaren kurs
umgesetzt hat doch gesagt wir lassen
niemanden mehr ins land und hat die
grenzen zu gemacht aber das doch genau
der punkt wenn ich nicht mehr weiß wer
in mein land kommen wichtig kontrolle
haben die sicherheitsbehörden ja auch
bestätigt wenn ich die kontrolle darüber
verlieren und nicht mehr weiß wen ich
mir ins land hole und sage ich konnte
die gründe
können alle kommen
oder gibt es für die einen zeitpunkt
oder woran machen sie fest wenn
integrationspolitik gelungen ist wenn
der erste syrer der deutsche frau
heiratet und zwei blonde kinder bekommt
oder was ist für sie ausschlaggebend
wenn die wenn die statistiken besser
werden wenn der hut herunter geht ja
wonach machen sie eine genommen der
integration zahlen die gerade genannt
habe eins ist auch klar da waren glaube
ich ganz ganz viele auch firmenchefs in
der zeit ja komplett verblendet die
erdachten es kommen nur top ausgebildete
manager und zahnärzte in dieses land
also es gab viele vorstandsvorsitzende
beispielsweise in von der lg jubelt hat
unsere alles wunderbar und wenn man das
jetzt mit den zahlen vergleicht die wir
sehen dann ist möglicherweise der ein
oder andere geblendet gewesen von einer
euphorie die im land herrscht geherrscht
hat gibt es auch ich gar kein vorwurf
aber am ende geht es schon darum dass
ein land wie deutschland mit einem sehr
sehr gut ausgebauten sozialsystemen das
ist ja nun mal so schon ein bisschen die
kontrolle behält darüber wer zu uns
kommt und wer nicht und damit meine ich
gar nicht dass hier das asylrecht
ausgehebelt werden soll aber das was
frau schimpft gerade sagte das asylrecht
muss konsequent angewendet werden wir
hier kein bleiberecht hat der muss auch
wieder gehen unsere wanderung starboard
ordnung es darf nicht vermischt werden
mit fachkräfte zuwanderung
den mut haben zu sagen wer zu uns kommen
darf und wer hier arbeiten zuwanderung
ihres asylrecht kann es nicht geben und
was hätte man tun können die ampel
übrigens weil wir gerade die ampel so
gelobt haben was denn die möchten genau
die ich habe in der korona politik
wird sich wahrscheinlich ändern aber ich
sage es mal so man hätte zu diesem
zeitpunkt nichts anders machen können
die europäische union ist ja dann unter
der hand anders verfahren also die
griechen gehen ja schon lange dass inter
schon lange dazu übergegangen boote
dieser auf dem mittelmeer aufbringen
zurückzuschicken die türkei das ist nach
europäischen recht unzulässig weil die
weil asylanträge gar nicht gestellt
werden können weil die menschen da keine
chance haben zu begründen warum sie
darüber wollen